[Music]
i have spent my career so far
working and living in two very different
worlds
the first is the world of politics where
i wrote speeches and made ads on two
presidential campaigns
the second
is the world of business where i led
special projects at a major technology
company
i get asked the exact same question
all the time
so tell me
do the politicians and the ceos really
hate each other as much as they look
like they do on tv when they're
screaming at each other all the time
that question
makes me really sad
it makes me sad because it says
something about our society that
everyone just kind of assumes that our
political leaders and our business
leaders despise each other
but you know what makes me even sadder
it's actually more true than i would
like to admit
because i've seen firsthand how this
collapsing relationship between our
political leaders and our business
leaders
this lack of decency this lack of
respect this lack of fundamental
communication is causing massive
problems for society
just look around
it's no secret that things are pretty
screwed up our planet is literally on
fire our democracy is teetering on the
edge and people all around us are angry
for good reason
we are facing a set of three once in
many generation challenges
the first is climate change
the second is weakening belief in
democracy
and the third
is widespread inequality
and
these aren't just government problems
and they're not just business problems
they are everyone problems
and while most of us inherently
understand this
we don't talk
about the next
logical step
which is to solve these problems
we first need to fix the broken
relationship between business and
government
so what are these problems that we need
to solve
i know it's hard talking about difficult
issues like this so i find it's helpful
to talk about specific stories so let's
do that for each of these three
first let's talk about the climate
for decades california has been allowed
by the federal government to set
stricter car emission standards than the
rest of the country
but when president trump came into
office he got into a lawsuit with the
state of california
to stop this from happening
general motors along with several other
car makers signed on to this lawsuit and
actively encouraged president trump to
get involved
but then
on november 7th 2020 president biden won
the 2020 election
and just 16 days later general motors
made a big announcement
they said they were dropping their
support of the lawsuit and we're
thrilled to work with the new
administration to tackle climate change
what does it tell us about our society
that one of the biggest companies in the
country changed its mind on one of the
most important problems facing our
society
just because an election happened
ask yourself
is that what bold values driven
corporate leadership looks like
second let's talk about the heart of
those elections our democracy
most of us here have probably seen
political ads online
in fact some of you may even hate them
in which case i'm really sorry some of
them are definitely my fault
and some of you may have heard of
something called the federal election
commission or the fpc the government
agency responsible for regulating
political ads
but here's what you may not know
the last time that the fec updated its
regulations on online political ads was
in the year
2006
yes
2006
that was back before a tiny company
called facebook was even open to the
public
and a full five years before snapchat
was even founded
so online political ads right now are
pretty much the wild west
and it's gotten so bad in recent cycles
that the platforms like google and
facebook have had to step in and set
their own rules because the fdc was not
doing its job
ask yourself
is that what strong government oversight
of the business world
looks like
third
let's talk about our last generational
challenge widespread inequality
a few years ago doordash had an unusual
tipping policy
dashers would go out and deliver food
and doordash would guarantee them a
minimum payment to ensure that if a
customer did not tip them they would
still bring a certain amount home
that's a great idea
but if a customer did tip them
doordash would lower their payment to
the dasher by the exact same amount as
the tip
so doordash was basically like thank you
very much for the money and put it in
its pocket
there was a huge uproar when this came
out
the ceo apologized the policy was
changed
and while nothing indicates that this
was purposely malicious
ask yourself
where were the government regulators who
should have been making rules to ensure
that everyone in the gig economy could
earn a fair wage
and where were the corporate executives
who could have spoken to dashers to
understand how this policy would have
impacted them
now that we've talked through these
three examples
i would bet there's at least one person
in this audience who's thinking
something like this
geez this guy is kind and naive
what does he expect that all these folks
in the political world and all these
folks in the business world are just
going to get along come on live in
reality they have such opposing
interests
and that's a fair point believe me i've
heard it before
but here is what that argument misses
our political leaders and our business
leaders have one
very common interest
and that's keeping a stable
society
and a stable society
includes a stable planet
a stable democracy
and a stable people
because here is a fundamental truth
you cannot make money and you cannot
govern in the long run when everything
around you is going crazy
that's why these aren't just government
problems and they're not just business
problems they are everyone problems
and it is naive
incredibly ridiculously laughably naive
to believe that we can keep a stable
society for decades into the future
when our political leaders and our
business leaders cannot even approach
each other with goodwill
but here is the good news things are
changing
rebecca henderson a professor at harvard
business school has been writing over
the past few years about the need to
reimagine capitalism to fight climate
change
and larry fink the leaders of one of the
world's largest asset managers has been
writing recently about the need for
companies to find profit and purpose
but we need all of our leaders to take
action and that's where everyone here
today comes in
because remember both of those companies
that i just talked about general motors
and doordash
well their ceos are both stanford mba
alumni
so that means
in ten years
maybe even five
you
could be them
so here's what we need to do
first
for all the business leaders here today
before making a big decision
ask yourself
this question
in 10 years from now
will this decision
make society a better place
or a worse place
you might be surprised how many
decisions have a clear-cut answer to
that very simple question
second for all the political leaders
here
before making a big decision
ask yourself
this question
in 10 years from now
will this decision help those companies
make the right choices for society
because your job is to set the market's
rules to incentivize those businesses to
make good decisions not just for their
shareholders but for all of us and
especially your constituents
third
and for all the students here today the
future leaders
there is a change coming to the way
business interacts with the wider world
if you listen closely you can hear it
coming
think deeply about the role you have to
play in that movement
think about the companies you join and
the projects you take on
because they really do matter
fourth and this is for everyone here
do not wait for someone else to take the
lead we do not have the time to waste we
all need to get started on this today
because remember these aren't just
government problems and they're not just
business problems they are everyone
problems and we need to work together to
solve them
so if you're sitting here today and
you're already worried about what the
plan is going to look like for your kids
or you can't even imagine what's going
to happen in the next election
or you walk down the street and are
horrified
by the inequality you see all around you
you already know
how high the stakes are
so
what are you going to do about it
[Applause]
[Music]
you